Let’s start with a question and, please,
don’t cheat and look it up on Google…
How many immigrants have been deported by
Donald Trump?
Think about it!
During the electoral campaign, Donald Trump
couldn’t have made his point more clear:
he wouldn’t accept any more illegal immigrants.
Right?
So… check out this chart!
If you pay attention, you will see that, deportations-wise,
Obama was stricter on immigration than Trump.
Does this mean that Trump loves immigrants
and deserves a Peace nobel prize?
Of course not!
In fact, there are many nuances to discuss
about this chart.
But I wanted to show it to you to make a point:
when it comes to immigration, words are one
thing and facts are a totally different one.
So why are we talking about this now?
Because of this…
Migrants at Southern border top 100K for 2nd
month in a row
Yes, you heard that right… at the moment,
the American continent is dealing with one
of the biggest refugee crises in recent history.
But let’s hear more details about this from
Xander…
Erik…
Of course, Simon!
In recent years, hundreds of thousands of
Central American immigrants have been crossing
Mexican territory until they reach the border
with the US.
Many of them are children and women who make
the whole road by foot and often arrive with
diseases and malnutrition.
And yes, I said they cross Mexican soil because
they come from Central America.
Countries like Honduras, Guatemala, and El
Salvador have become a living hell: violence,
drug gangs and, of course, extreme poverty
have caused all of these people to flee their
homelands.
So now you might wonder… how did Trump answer
this challenge?
Of course, he did this…
Donald Trump threatens Mexico with 5% imports
tariff over illegal immigration
Yes, you heard that right…
Donald Trump wants to pass the hot potato
to Mexico.
But here is the big question…
What does Mexico do about it?
First of all, the Mexican President is this
man you see on the screen: ANDRES MANUEL LOPEZ
OBRADOR, also known as AMLO.
AMLO is a hardcore left wing politician who,
you guessed it, is no big fan of Trump.
During the electoral campaign, he said he
would be compassionate with immigrants crossing
into his country.
But, now he says he’s being pushed by the
White House to take a hard stance on immigration:
Mexico has a lot to lose if America imposes
tariffs on them.
So AMLO had to send in the troops to stop
the immigrants on the Southern border.
So again, evil Donald Trump is pushing a poor,
good hearted politician to do his dirty work,
right?
Well… this is the narrative we have heard
so far on many media outlets.
But… is it really that simple?
For example, here’s a good question… where
would be the big deal if Mexico took in more
refugees?
Similar arrangements have been made with other
countries like Turkey and they seemed to work…
but here’s the thing…
Have you ever wondered about the immigration
policy in Mexico?
Well… you should.
Here are some numbers.
14% of the US population are immigrants.
The OCDE average is 13%.
But Mexico has just 1%.
Yes, you heard that right.
Mexico is no country for foreigners.
So Today’s question is… how does Mexican
immigration policy actually work?
What is Mexico actually doing to manage the
refugee crisis?
Are they really doing what Trump wants?
Today we are going to answer to all of these
questions but, before we do, let’s take
a look back at the history.
THE MIGRANT CARAVAN
I know what you’re thinking now… why are
so many central americans leaving their countries
now?
Let’s be honest here, Honduras, Guatemala,
and El Salvador have never been prosperous
countries.
But… if we have learned anything from history,
it’s that what goes bad can go even worse.
Between 2010 and 2012, the crime rates skyrocketed
here.
Honduras suffered a coup d’etat in 2009.
El Salvador is suffering street violence from
the so-called MARAS, or street gangs.
Something similar is happening in Guatemala.
And part of it can be explained because of
drug trafficking.
You see, during the 80s, narco violence was
focused on Colombia.
Those were the times of Pablo Escobar, the
Cali cartel, and the FARC.
But after 2000, Colombia managed to reduce
the violence.
Yes, cocaine production is still there, but
the different cartels have reached a sort
of PAX MAFIOSA.
They are still in the drug business, but they
don’t kill each other.
But now, a similar kind of drug violence has
moved to other parts of the continent.
Also, some people blame climate change.
According to this theory, Climate Change is
creating droughts in Central America.
If the crops aren’t productive, people starve
and have to leave.
Add to this NGOs like PUEBLOS SIN FRONTERAS,
which organize the so-called migrante caravans.
They offer logistical support so thousands
of migrants can start their journeys to the
US border.
But of course, it’s not only about NGOs.
It’s also about human traffickers.
As you can see, there are many explanations,
but the truth is this is an exodus.
For a better understanding, in 2007, the US
border patrols apprehended 16,000 Guatemalans.
11 years later, in 2018, the figure increased
to 116,000 Guatemalans.
And now you might wonder… are these Immigrants
or refugees?
And to be fair, we should talk about refugees.
Officially, they are considered economic migrants
but, let’s be honest… these are not ambitious
people trying to achieve the American dream.
In most cases, they’re just people escaping
extreme violence.
In many cases, they’re women and children
threatened by a Mara or a drug gang.
They would almost certainly be killed if they
went back.
This is why they’ll do whatever it takes
to leave.
And I say whatever it takes because they really
take no prisoners.
There are more than 3000 kilometers or 1800
miles between Guatemala and El Paso, Texas.
Many of these migrants do the journey by foot.
Others do it by the so-called, ‘death train’…
you can imagine why they call it this.
So what happens when these people cross the
border?
Most of them are apprehended and deported
to their home countries.
But let’s be fair here!
Some make it to America.
US authorities have already created many programs
to attend to those refugees.
Just in 2017, more than 59,000 Central Americans
stayed in the country.
Is that too much or too little?
It’s up to you to make your own judgment.
But the question is… how many did Mexico
accept?
We don’t have the exact number, but is much
smaller.
Here’s a number we can give you.
In Mexico today, there are about 50,000 Guatemalans
while America hosts 900,000.
And you might wonder… why?
Why can’t central americans refugees remain
in Mexico?
Let’s have a look, shall we?
NO COUNTRY FOR FOREIGNERS
In Mexico they’ve made it very clear: not
all migrants are made equal.
For example, if you are watching this video
from America... don’t worry!
Mexico welcomes you with open arms.
In fact, most of the migrants living there
come from the States.
Don’t believe me?
Look at this chart.
Mexico has 1,200,000 migrants today.
Of those, 900,000 are American, 27,000 are
Spanish, and Only 15,000 come from Honduras.
Mexico has more Germans than Salvadoreans.
And this is surprising considering that Salvadoreans
are much closer, speak the same language,
and are leaving their country by the thousands.
And you might wonder… why is this?
Is it pure chance?
Do central Americans don’t like Mexico?
Of course not.
Just look at what the Mexican immigration
law says.
The Secretary of Government can neglect the
entry to the country to a foreigner or change
the characteristics of their migrant status
anytime the demographic balance requires it
Yes, you heard that right… this demographic
balance is just a nice way of saying; poor
people are not allowed here.
And when it says ‘changing the characteristics
of their migrant status’, it basically means
they can kick you out any time they want.
But OK!
OK!
I know what many of you might say.
Things are changing.
And, of course, they are.
Just look at what the former Mexican president
said in October 2018.
Today Mexico gives you its hand.
We want you and all the migrants to feel protected
and calm.
In order to support you, Mexico is launching
today the ‘Feel like home!’ plan.
Here, in Mexico, you can receive healthcare
assistance, education and you will have a
temporary ID to get your residence permit.
The man you see on the screen is ENRIQUE PENA
NIETO, the former Mexican president.
This was one of his last policies before leaving
office.
His successor, AMLO agreed with this plan.
And Donald Trump also agreed.
All of a sudden, his Southern neighbour accepted
migrants so America didn’t have to.
But… wait a minute because, as we said at
the beginning, words are one thing and facts
are another.
Sure, at the beginning, the Mexican government
accepted people from Central America.
In a few months, more than 20,000 Guatemalans,
Hondurans and Salvadoreans came to the country
asking for a visa.
And how did Mexicans like that?
Well… not so much!
According to a Survey, 58% of Mexicans don’t
want migrants to enter the country.
Exactly! Trump is not alone in hating migrants
and refugees.
Add to this the fact that Mexican authorities
can’t deal with so many people crossing
the Southern border.
Think about it… you need to build shelters,
print those visas, and feed all those people.
And you need money for that.
And… political capital.
And the new Mexican president doesn’t want
to risk any of those two things.
He is extremely popular and he doesn’t want
that to stop being the case.
So, with Mexican society against migrants
and the army and the police with no resources,
the new Mexican president had only one choice.
Mexico triples deportations of Central Americans
with LOPEZ OBRADOR
The new Government has removed more than 45,000
people in 5 months.
15,000 of those were in April.
So now you might wonder… what are the consequences
of this policy?
Of course, the biggest victims are those hundreds
of thousands Central Americans who cannot
stay in Mexico or America.
But this is not the only consequence.
Think about it… if AMLO doesn’t want the
refugees… where will they go?
Exactly!
They keep making their way up to the States.
So the hot potato falls back into Donald Trump’s
hands.
This is in May 2019 and it’s when the White
House threatens Mexico with 5% tariffs.
In other words, this is when the Mexican government
finds itself between the hammer and the anvil.
If the Mexican president takes in so many
refugees, Mexicans will hate him.
If he doesn’t… Trump will punish him.
So what’s his solution?
Well… just look…
U.S. Government's 'Remain in Mexico' Policy
is Expanding, Stranding More People in a Dangerous
Mexican City
In other words, in May 2019, Trump went to
AMLO and said…
Look, Mexico, dude…
I don’t give two shits about what you do
with Central Americans.
Really.
Not my problem…
Wanna take them?
All yours!
Wanna deport them?
Of course!
You can deport them to…
Canada, Russia or Mars…
I just don’t wanna see one more of those
people crossing my border!
And if I do… you’ll pay for it!’
So what was the easiest solution to AMLO?
Basically, letting all those immigrants stay
in a ghetto.
Mexico has deployed 6000 troops to contain
them.
So they haven’t been deported, but they
cannot continue on their way or integrate
into Mexican society.
For example, in the most recent months, many
of those immigrants have been concentrated
in cities like NUEVO LAREDO, at the border
with US, in really poor conditions.
There are no doctors, no food, and violence
is starting to rise.
But the worst place of all is the city of
TAPACHULA, at the border with GUATEMALA.
Over 20,000 and 30,000 asylum pledges have
been registered here.
And the Mexican army is stationed here, stopping
people from going any farther north.
Lots of murders have been happening already.
So, in other words, those refugees ended up
in the same situation that they were escaping
from.
Neither America nor Mexico wants them.
And while they keep passing the hot potato
to each other, people are dying.
So the question now goes to you…
How do you think this problem could be solved?
Do you think Mexico could do anything to accept
the refugees or is it only America’s job?
Could they reach a deal to share responsibility?
Please, leave your answer in the comment section
below.
Also, visit RECONSIDERMEDIA.COM, the podcast
that provided the vocals on this episode that
were not mine.
Don’t forget that we publish brand new videos
every week so subscribe to this channel and
hit that bell button so you won’t miss any
posts.
If you liked this video, give us a thumbs
up and, as always, I’ll see you next time.